I was muted.
Hello everybody, welcome to...
I forgot my bunny ears!
I set up everything else.
One second.
I forgot the most important thing!
I can't believe it.
I cannot believe it.
Wait, they're kind of big, aren't they?
It's a bit better.
Maybe, maybe.
That's a bit better.
Maybe.
Do they look even?
Thank you!
I like mates and money, girls.
Really?
Rascal does not dream of a made bunny girl.
Now we're ready!
That's why I love Toki.
She is a made...
No, it's so a bunny girl, you're so right.
One of them looks...
It's only when I look certain ways one looks bigger than the
other.
I fell asleep before the end of the collab last night, but
you did great for your first helldive.
Thank you!
Hopefully the devs fix that glitch that kept saying you were
killed by an innocent kettle.
I don't know what was going on.
So crazy, right?
And drink those things with the five gifted!
Put on the bunny ears mint.
We got a bunny garden to venture to.
If you don't have bunny ears on, it scares them away, you
know?
It's a fact.
It's a real fact.
Hold on, I am going to make myself a wee bit like that.
There we go.
This is a different busting than usual, huh?
Also, welcome back, Minto!
Thank you, nap nap!
What do you mean by that?
It's always the same kind of busting.
Love the collab last night.
Thank you!
So...
I am a big fan of curate games.
They always just appeal to me in the best ways.
Also, can you guys see my...
my eye...
tracker?
Is it on?
Can you see it?
We can see it?
I tried to make it not so, um, invasive.
I tried to make it like a little bit more, um, a little bit,
uh, what's the word?
A little less obvious.
Subtle, subtle, subtle.
It's a bit hard to see.
actually I didn't want it to like I didn't want it to like
get too in the way you know but also I changed the opacity
on it when I set it up earlier and now I don't know how to
change it we'll see yeah it's a little less distracting
let's see how it is in the game it might be easier to see
there Yeah, of course we can't have it get in the way of the
goods.
That'd be ridiculous.
Okie dokie.
So yeah, this game, like I said, I'm a fan of Q-Rite games.
This one is very much like Dream City Club, so my neurons
were especially...
Perked?
My neurons were especially activated.
As for the girls...
Can you see my mouse?
Yeah.
It's where the girls...
I'm thinking...
The...
The side pony girl looks like...
She's catching my interest the most.
But usually I like inner color.
But she's kind of like Gyaru-esque, so...
I'm kind of a fan.
So...
She's sassy!
I'm like... I mean her skirt...
Sorry, I'm kind of...
blocking it.
Everything?
I don't know what their names are.
That's the one thing about being like a streamer is wanting
to watch something, but also being like, no, I can't watch
it because I have to be the one, like I want to have a raw
reaction when I stream it, you know?
So, they're all good.
Short-haired tomboy is peak for me.
She's very cute.
And she's got kind of like a heme cut Going on a little bit,
but I like the pink the the blonde to pink fade.
I'm a big fan of that Middle girl is cute.
She's just kind of She's kind of plain so it's like you know
not my type exactly
Middle one has default thigh highs are they thigh highs or
are they tights?
Oh wait, maybe that is a sliver Maybe that is a sliver of...
thigh.
Right there.
Looks like Tyson meat.
No, I think that's a sliver of thigh.
Right there.
Anyway.
The booba variety is lacking.
Yeah!
I mean, she's definitely the biggest.
Um...
It might have been nicer maybe to get some petangirls or
something.
But that's okay.
What's under extra?
I'm keep wondering.
Event CG.
This building?
That is...
Thank you!
This building I'm pretty sure is where the Chubby Girl Maid
Cafe is.
There was some other ones in there.
Does
this take place in Akiba?
Does this take place in Akiba?
I'm scanning the stream.
I'm unsure.
Fakiba?
Don't call it that!
Tutorial.
For what?
Event CG, album, and mystery.
Garden!
Alright, let's start.
Let's start!
What am I doing?
Me starting this game.
I'm
pretty sure.
That's so funny.
Why did I make such a big mistake?
I would never do something like that normally.
My company fired me.
The bunny maid girl in the lower left is the best IMH up.
Stop it.
Stop it!
Not even a bunny most of the time.
It is what it is.
Not the first time it's happened.
Oh wait, sorry.
I forgot to read your thing, Rico.
I think I reacted, but I forgot to read it.
Since my cat decided that he needs to be on my lap right
now.
How are things going with the quest to get Butaro a friend?
Wait, is it...
Oh yeah, Butaro.
Um...
I got him a friend.
I'm
a cat of friend!
Actually, I've been trying to, like, I've been not wanting
to say so much because I didn't want to say anything until,
like, they were adjusted entirely.
They're still, like, getting to know each other.
But, um, but, uh, because, you know, if they were, like, if
there was, like, something really, really wrong and they,
like, they couldn't get along at all, I wanted, you know,
might have to like take her back and i didn't want to be
like i got a friend and then i have to give her back to the
shelter or anything so but she's very very sweet she's very
very cute i'll talk more about her later though yeah yeah
i'm thankful they hired me in the first place i have nothing
but gratitude for the company my boss even cried for me when
they fired me he said i'm sorry i couldn't help you out They
told me that this company wasn't the right fit for me and
that there are other places where I could shine.
It was nice of them to say that.
Is there really somewhere out there?
Some place that would take in a fool like me?
Am I haito?
Am I haito for real?
Even if I could get another job somewhere else, I would just
mess everything up for the people there.
She's got a fetish for fine art, a pair of thigh highs, an
oversized sweatshirt, you know what I mean?
Even if I could just get...
Oh yeah, I would mess everything up for the people there.
Maybe my life is done for.
Maybe my afterlife is done for.
I don't even think it had started.
I want to play this too eventually so I can't watch the
stream.
Let me know what you think when you play it.
On a scale of zero to Stinky House.
No, she's perfect.
She's not Stinky at all.
She's so cute.
Oh my god.
She's my little princess.
Time to drink my problems away.
Pretty sure there's a bar somewhere in this building.
I like the little open sign.
Oh wow.
We don't have that much money.
Oh!
See...
Oh, she's actually so cute.
Wait, I'm sorry?
Do you guys want me to read what she says too?
I guess it might be easier, right?
Just throwing out a guess here, but did something bad happen
to you?
That's why you're trying to drink and forget everything?
Are you trying to get me to go to your hostess club?
You're wrong.
You just happened to catch my eye before I got to work.
You caught my eye.
She looks like a little country bumpkin.
She's got like this plaid, like, ass caught on and, like,
her jean skirt.
It's just...
You look so tired as if you're after life, sorry, your life
is over.
Eyes up, girl.
My eyes are up here.
I think it's a little off, but that's okay.
You might be right.
Oh, yay!
You are!
Oh my gosh, she's like, I knew it!
Yes, your life is... Oh my gosh, you just want to throw
yourself off Mante Bashi Bridge right now!
I get it!
Oh my gosh, I'm so glad that I was right, that you are so
down on your luck and such a sad, sad pathetic soul right
now.
Yeah, you should apologize!
Oh, gomanasari.
This isn't something to be happy about.
Gomanasari.
Honto ni, gomen.
Hi, that's all.
Hello, thank you!
I shouldn't have hit it right on the bullseye.
It's so sad to think your life is over.
Yeah, I know.
What should I do?
If I invite him in, then I'll really become a...
A trout?
A trout.
Sorry.
Oh, I forgot that when I get out of the game, it, um.
A trout?
A prophet!
Thank you for the vibe.
Thank you!
I can't leave someone so hurt out in the cold!
A solicitor.
Oh.
I'll be a trout.
Hold on.
Oh, it's...
a bit more accurate now, maybe.
No, not really.
But that's okay.
Um, what do you mean?
It's a type of fish.
It's like a salesperson.
Got it.
You don't have to come into the shop.
You can just have a sneak peek.
That's right.
I don't know what's going on.
The truth is, I work here.
Oh.
I didn't know they opened this kind of bar here It's
someplace where I can drink with girls So when I was in
Japan For the two months I was there Actually by my train
station Every time I would get home There was a bunny girl
bar And it was kind of cold out So I couldn't see them in
the bunny girl Outfits But they had like giant coats on And
then the bunny ears it made it sexier because I couldn't see
like anything underneath but like you know I could see their
legs and I could see the bunny ears and I just imagined like
the the suit underneath and I was like wow this is so sexy
keep the jacket on girl keep it on
yeah so I was like I got to see bunny girls almost every day
It was so awesome.
The power of imagination.
It's some place I can drink with girls?
That's like any bar in Akiba, to be honest.
I've never been in a shop like this before.
It's clean, and the girls are...
So cute.
I guess I'll give it a try.
Oh, you're gonna get me in trouble, sir.
Wait, why?
I can't come in?
Oh my god, you're teased!
That's all for today.
I'll give you just a glimpse if you come inside that I'm
really a tout.
Appointment only?
I give you the right to come to the shop as a customer.
Whenever you're interested, I'll be waiting for you to come.
Haha, you're so sincere.
Their life isn't over.
You'll be okay.
I know you will.
Oh my gosh.
Because of Bunny Girls!
Bunny Girls will save me!
This place actually looks so fancy.
Right now, even if it was small, Oh, sorry.
I've been so sleepy today.
I know you smiled.
That means you're not done yet.
Arigato.
She's so country.
Y'all.
I'll be here at this shop waiting for you.
I'm looking forward to the next time we can see each other.
All right.
what was her deal she was so strange she doesn't even know
me it's interesting I like the 3D mix with the with the CG
it's cool but I guess I do feel a little better I'm such a
simple guy me too, Haito I wish I could name myself now I
don't know if I really want to get drunk and forget
everything I'm just going to go home
Oh my god.
Oh, wait, isn't that the prison princess girls?
On the wall?
Also, when I saw that in a brief moment, I thought it was
Fulamoko.
I thought it was Fulamoko.
Gorillas.
Is it sad that I recognized prison princess before gorillas
at all?
his little ipad he's got his computer with sticky notes
we're jobless now we are a neat my life isn't over huh more
yihong go please cash kumari master what color were her eyes
mint
green wait were they actually let's go no way why would i
take something a girl said to me seriously when I don't even
know her name.
Also, when she works at a bar that, like, relies on
ensnaring men.
She didn't even seem to be joking around, but, you know.
They were green?
Oh my gosh, I was tossing between green and purple.
I mean, it's not like anyone has ever told me that my life
is done.
I'm the only one who thinks that.
If I don't finish it myself, maybe it's still possible to
start again.
Finish what?
Oh, hello?
I'm sorry for calling you without notice.
You know how you were saying work was busy and you needed
help?
Do you still need help?
If you'd like, would you take me?
Oh, Q!
What was that?
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, no, I'm skipping.
It's been a week since I started my new job.
Wow!
What should I use my money on?
Wait, I still have the same amount.
Uh, I haven't gotten any more money.
How much is $1,500 yen to US dollars?
Curious question.
Well, back in the day, it probably would have been about
$150 US dollars, but with the yen being as bad as it is now,
I'd say about $100 to $110.
Yeah, about $100.
Sheesh.
96?
No way.
Okay.
I saw like when people were going to like from Japan I saw
like they were flying to Hawaii they were bringing they were
bringing their own food because the conversion rate like I'm
like Hawaii is already very expensive but with the
conversion rate it would have been so much more so they were
like bringing their own their their own food to like eat in
Hawaii that's so sad so bad
Notoriously expensive.
Oh, the conversion rate.
So bad.
That being said, me being positive is all thanks to her.
Should I go to that chick's shop?
Yeah, let's go see that chick.
Oh, this week's salary.
Wow!
Nice.
Payment is made every Saturday for your new job.
Spend it carefully.
Cha-ching!
Cha-ching, cha-ching.
Oh.
Okay, okay, okay.
album vacation wait wait I'm sorry you can gift a vacation
to a cast member not me I don't go on vacation they go on
vacation shop purchase gifts to give to the cast my schedule
you can apply for dispatch it takes two days for dispatch do
we not have a job anymore you can gamble you can view taken
you can sleep and let the day pass you can also rest your
overworked body save and load
interesting mc is a simp
i think it was this shop here i'm a bit nervous though wow
Ah, it's getting too much.
Oh, it's so cute.
Oh, that's so cute.
Oh, bwny girl!
Yeah, k-k-k-k-kawaii.
Ah, it's getting too much.
Vacations, thanks.
Oh, o kairi no-sai- Oh, oh, oh my god!
Oh my god, this is- Oh, my god, this is- Oh, the man.
This shop is filled with criminals!
It's all the guys from Detective Conan!
It's all the guys that have killed someone that committed
the crimes in Detective Conan!
Oh my god.
I saw that.
Saw what?
So who?
Well, what did you see?
ViviCorps, thank you for the five gifted!
Thank you!
The customer who looked tired!
You came!
any but kind of i like the ribbon on her head
that's right the customer who look tired i'm here which
starter will mint choose yellow red or blue
that makes me happy i wouldn't know what something is like
so this is a new experience for me Of course it is okay.
It's my birthday today.
Can I get a happy birthday?
Of course Melty!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Melty.
Happy birthday, Pyong Pong.
I'm hearing Maid Mint say my name again after all this time.
Dang, I'm lucky that Detective Manga is...
Hey, Conan!
Oh, I just realized my thing kind of goes on my face.
Oh, there we go.
That's right, I've never been here.
I'll give you a brief explanation on how it works.
Please, I don't know anything, so this will help.
The name of the shop is Bunny Garden, a fun place to drink.
That's all.
It seems like I should understand, but I don't.
Well, you'll gradually...
get used to it so it's okay i'll be really happy if we come
here lots of times i agree to do that i have to work hard at
my current he's already sipping maybe he feels like he feels
like he owes her you know he's just like you saved my life
so i have to i owe you i owe you you know
I like her, I like her smug face.
It's over for my guy.
Well, then I want to be able to give...
I want you to be able to do your best, so I hope I can give
you lots of healing.
That makes sense.
I feel like I can work harder if I feel better.
It's decided.
I didn't hear your order.
This is the menu.
She's so cute.
I'm sorry for what I said about just being too plain before.
I'll have a drink.
What drink?
Did you want?
Customers must purchase a drink.
A price your drink could increase your likability.
Oh, ho, oh, ho, ho.
Let's see.
A Cassius Orange.
Cassius Liquor and Specialty Orange Juice.
With a low alcohol percentage, it is popular among women.
Oh, my gosh.
The fanciest beer I've ever seen in my life.
Blueberry Liquor.
I think I just got paid today, so...
Oh, deluxe.
This luxury champagne is rare and loved by celebrities!
It's very high in alcohol content, so be careful.
Lab Parry.
Highest quality grapes in age for several years.
It's popular for its fresh and mature taste.
Oh.
I thought I said Mori Calliope.
I'll have a gin and tonic, please.
Come and write... Why?
Who is Jin?
Shouldn't it... Wait, isn't it spelled with a G instead of a
J?
The green bunny girl saved my life.
What are you talking about?
Is it... Is it... Um... Is it because it's like copyrighted?
Sake.
It's a bit dry.
Easy drink.
A fine wine.
Vintage umeshu.
Bunny trap?
Infused with a sweet, gentle aroma, many people tend to
drink too much of...
Bunny punch!
Has a high alcohol content, but women seem to be fond of it.
Wait, I'm drinking this, right?
Or are they drinking it?
Maybe I'll try the bunny max.
Has a particular...
Strong peculiarity is not for everyone.
Oh, fill you up with power when drunk.
Recovering from depression.
parasocial what do you mean no i mean yes now you're
recovering from depression yippee so this is my order okay
let's go for the trap because i feel like we've been trapped
wait a second choosing for me choosing for her i just
noticed on the side i got paid today let's get ourselves a
bunny trap and uh we can get her the bunny punch
I want to treat the cast members to a drink.
Some drinks that are more preferred than others, and some
are easier to get drunk on.
If you don't treat them to drinks, they will prioritize
other customers.
Treat your cast member to a drink.
I won't buy.
They will just leave me alone.
You saved my life.
Bunny!
Paz!
It tastes great.
Wait, I should probably prioritize the girl that I want to
get with, right?
Before I spend expensive drinks on her?
Uh-oh.
I think I messed up.
You can talk to the cast.
Something might happen.
What does that mean?
You can give a gift to each cast member once a day.
Gifts can be purchased from home.
You can treat the cast members to food.
There may be a preference for different foods.
I have no presents.
Let's just talk to her.
Let's get to know her.
I'm getting kind of nervous.
Why?
I'm using therapy and medication.
The player kicker is the one recovering from depression.
Birds with no goddess.
Keep taking your meds.
My eyes are up there!
What do you mean?
Wow, look at her bunny ears.
I mean, it's going to be the first time I meet this next
customer.
My heart feels like it's going to explode from how fast it
is.
Well,
what am I saying?
The purpose of this place is to make customers feel relaxed,
not stressed.
You mentioned how you like to look into roller coasters
rides, so I highly recommend the ACE documentary on
Aerodynamics.
They shape the modern landscapes of roller coasters.
Oh, thank you.
I will look into it.
Thank you.
But yeah, we're relaxed, we're relaxed.
If I'm going to stay like this, I'm sure the customer is
going to feel the same.
Come on now, you've got this.
She's like saying all of this to my face.
Don't ask what my job is.
Let's start off with the usual.
The first step in order to become friends.
You're the customer, so please, go right ahead with
everything you've got.
The first step.
Oh, okay.
What about a hug?
Oh, I'm cringing.
Oh, the toast is good.
The toast is good.
There are some things that affect likeability.
Choose your words carefully.
Where's my hug?
Oh, come on, girl.
Come on, little bunny girl.
Where's my hug?
Let's do the toast.
So a toast or something?
She liked it.
That's the spirit.
You seem eager to start drinking.
But don't you think sharing each other's names come first?
I read your name tag.
Wait, no.
Hold on.
Move your hands.
There we go.
Oh, she doesn't have a name tag.
I'm going to make a bunch of flashbacks.
I'd love to know more about you.
Right, my name is Mint Phantom.
Oh,
gosh.
I'm so jealous of everyone named Haito right now.
I'm so jealous of everyone named Haito.
Haito right now.
Wait, Minto?
Haito?
It's kind of close.
Right?
You don't need to keep looking at me like that.
The models in this game look so good, by the way.
Like the...
The faces are so cute.
I like actually how soft the features are.
Like they look like that.
They just look really good.
I wanted to remember your name and face, you see.
So I was doing my best to store that into my head.
Yeah, they look so cute.
They're so cute.
But there's no need to worry.
I've matched your face to your name now.
It's my turn now.
My name is Kana.
I don't mind if you give me a nickname, but I know, but I
sure hope you remember me.
I'll give you a nickname, alright.
From this day on, you're a bitch-chan.
Alright, I'll do my best to match your name to your face
then.
Bitch Chan Bitch Chan Bitch Chan Bitch Chan
Don't you guys ever seen?
Have you guys ever seen diabolic lovers?
Girl love that That was his nickname for the girl Are you
being mean?
No!
I'm trying to Riz her!
What are you talking about?
I watched the Otomei show and I know now!
I know!
Stop it, you're making me all flustered!
I didn't know it felt this embarrassing to be stared at!
Not diabolic lovers.
I suppose there's some things you learned from first-hand
experience.
I got a little smarter from this whole situation.
Oh my god.
Kind of grew one brain cell that day.
Don't change the genre on your own.
Ew.
Sorry.
Tell me more about yourself, Haidt-Kun.
I messed up real bad at work recently.
Because of that, the boss fired me.
So I've been assisting a friend at his work ever since.
That sounds wrong.
Is this what the kids call nagging?
What's that mean?
What's nagging?
If it's what the kids call, I don't know.
If I was in your shoes, I probably wouldn't even be able to
eat.
Though I'm sure words can't express just how awful you must
feel.
Oh, gaslighting.
Negative edging?
Hmm?
I got it.
Oh, egging!
I'm so sorry!
Oh my gosh.
Neging is pickup, Lingol.
We're treating women horribly, and they claim it gets all
the women.
Oh, that sounds like diabolic lovers, for real.
I'm going to do my absolute best in order for you to get
back on your feet.
Okay, I need to get myself to- I need to get myself
together.
Oh, I need to- Is it hot in here?
Try to be- I'm- I am, I am, I am!
I'm trying to be nice!
I'm trying- I'm using lingo that I learned from a show that
apparently was bad.
bad.
I'm...
I'm... I'm doing...
I bought her good... I've bought her the good juice, okay?
That time you spend here will be with a constant smile.
I can assure you that much.
I hope we get along, Haito, and then I'm gonna steal your
soul until you turn into this black silhouette of yourself
and you can never leave.
Does that mean we go three times?
The one, two, three?
Heyto, should I get you more drinks?
I can keep going, but I'll only continue if you want to.
There's a fee?
Oh my god, this place is so expensive and so real!
Oh my gosh.
Let's switch, yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
I thought you were going home already.
Oh gosh, I'm a sucker.
What drink did you want?
Wait, can I switch out?
Uh-oh.
Oh no, I'm stuck with her!
Dang.
Oh, I'm getting sucked dry.
Here, we'll go, we'll go with the...
I'm gonna go with the sake and she'll get the blueberry
liquor.
Can I have some too?
Oh wait, this is how I...
This is how I switch.
A customer called me, so I better get going.
I was just cheap-skating this guy.
I can't believe he is not buying me another drink.
I can't believe it.
Oh, bye-bye.
Who's gonna come over here?
Oh, oh, oh.
What's your name?
Hi.
Miuka.
Would you like to introduce yourself?
Oh, she's so cool.
She's cool, did it.
Oh, yeah.
You may call me Haito Kanda.
Oh.
You don't have to be polite with me.
I see.
I mean, okay, I'm Haito Kanda.
I help my friend for work.
You help your friends?
Yeah, I was working at a company up until recently, but I
got messed up and fired.
I don't know if that's like the first thing you want to keep
telling people, you know?
I don't know if like...
Hi, I'm Haito Kanda.
I got fired recently.
I'm Haito Kanda.
Fired.
right uh are you bad at holding a conversation are you a
person a few words are you angry are you mad that I lost my
money I got fired with Riz I'm thinking this one maybe it
seems not very offensive are you a person a few words oh oh
Ah, I guess I don't speak much.
She doesn't even use an honorific.
She just calls me Haito straight up.
She hates us, you guys.
She hates us.
I'm sorry.
What does that mean?
I'm like this.
I can't fix her.
I'm sorry, I'm like this.
Maybe you won't be able to have a good time.
It's okay.
Who knows what will happen.
We just met each other.
I think it would be nice if we could just take things slow.
No rush.
We already started to get to know each other.
Oh,
she's so cute.
Thank you.
Haito, you're a kind one, Haito.
Oh, sake.
She's so cute.
Do you want some alcohol?
What should I do?
Is there anything I should prepare?
Oh, extend?
Yes.
My efforts have been rewarded.
I want to drink something delicious.
What drink did you want?
Let's do the same thing that we did with Kana in the
beginning, right?
I get the bunny trap.
And she gets the...
Wait, do I have enough money?
9,000 just to say...
Wait, is there a table charge?
Wait, is there only two extent?
Like, wait, do I...
What?
Mm-hmm?
So would it be 9,000?
or 6,000?
Don't worry about it.
I'm gonna have the bunny trap.
Can I have a drink with you?
Oh, our little chibi is so cute.
I'm gonna get you the bunny punch.
Yata.
I like this.
Oh, Oh, cute!
Cute, cute, cute, cute, cute.
Oh, I think you just dumped it all over the ground.
She took one sip and was like, mm-mm.
Oh, wait, no, they put their drinks under the bar like that.
There's like a little shelf there.
Oh, that's so cute.
Um.
Is there anything you want to talk about?
You think tomorrow will be...
Oh yeah, the weather deck, let's go.
You think tomorrow will be sunny?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
Shall we look up the weather forecast?
Are you always curious about the weather?
Uh, not really.
I'm just making small talk.
Uh...
Sorry.
I didn't mean anything by that.
This is a business venture, and buddy stonks are through the
roof.
Yeah!
If you do go bankrupt, just get a loan.
They will understand.
Watching you play this on my birthday is certainly
interesting.
Exendo!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Exendo.
Happy birthday to you Happy birthday I love blue women Ah,
so true Gosh, she looks like one of my...
She looks like an Oshi I had that graduated I mean except in
maybe the The one report But she's...
I can't stop looking, seeing my Oshi
This is who I am all the time.
Is that okay with you?
It's all right with me.
We're just starting to get to know each other.
You're a peculiar one.
You laughed us now, didn't you?
You have a cute smile.
Thank you.
Thanks for the 20 gift.
It's getting late.
I should go home soon.
Oh!
So it is 9,000.
Oh my god.
If you can please the cast members in the shop, they will
see you out in a good mood when you leave.
We pleased them.
We did a good job Haito, who is sent off, is more motivated
to work and earn a higher salary for one week.
Higher motivation for work can lead to a raise and an
increase in base salary.
This should make up for part of the memberships.
I've missed these past years.
Also, my tickets to your karaoke bot.
I can't stop listening.
Stop!
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
There was no ticket.
What are you talking about?
Yeah, thanks for everything.
See you soon.
So it's this place here, right?
What?
Oh man, I'm gonna get a bento after this.
It was such a nice place and the customer service is great.
Maybe I'll go there for the time being.
bunny garden oh what can we get you can purchase gifts to
give to the cast on rare occasions the lineup may change
socks Gucci socks perfume makeup plush that is a really
expensive plush toy holy cow
Macarons are a good gift, right?
See, it's Gucci, but with a Q.
So wouldn't it not be Gucci?
I want macarons now.
I'm thinking about them.
When I lived in Japan, at Family Mart, they released a pack
of two macarons.
One was strawberry flavored, and the other one was
pistachio.
And I'd get it once a week.
It was so good.
It was so good!
Oh, I'm drooling think I'm yummy.
Which one was better?
I think I like the pistachio one.
I really...
Oh my god, turtles!
Tickets!
Sorry about the typos!
Stop, thank you!
Thank you!
Okay,
okay.
Let's get some macarons.
Cha-ching!
What's my schedule?
You can check the schedule except her birthday!
Oh, okay.
We can only see up until September.
What is the dispatch?
Oh, we're not recruiting.
Okay.
You can get the vacation to a cast member who invited you.
We can go.
Oh,
wait.
Okay.
There we go.
We can gamble.
You can try gambling.
Of course, sometimes you win and sometimes you lose.
Keep your fingers crossed and consider taking on the
challenge.
Yeah, I do want to gamble a little bit.
Gambling?
Oh my, wait!
What?
That's a lot of money.
No, no, no.
Save, save the game!
Save the game!
Oh my gosh, so cute.
Woohoo!
Is this a hobby?
What does that mean?
Oh, I don't have any.
I thought I took that picture.
Oh, sold out.
Okay, time to go to Bunny Garden.
I'm rich again.
Now is my time to rest up and recover.
This is the only place that can heal my mind.
I think I am Haito, and I'm realizing very quickly that I
have a problem.
The cast member who likes you the most will serve you
immediately after you enter.
Increase your likeability, and you might end up with the
cast?
Oh, you came.
I'm glad.
What drink did you want?
Just give me a...
Hmm.
Honka pedonka Jesus.
Miuka.
Is that, wait, Miuka is the short-haired one, right?
I am still curious about the other girl, but I feel like
she's kind of out of my league.
I feel like she's kind of like the type that's, that
wouldn't, that would scare me.
You know, like, the one that's like like she's so like she's
too she's too social you know what i mean give her a chance
maybe women scare me yeah just gyalu gyalu gyalu so true um
let's skip i'm gonna get just uh i'm gonna get a fine wine
because i i earned a lot of money gambling today.
Can I have some too?
No.
I see ya.
Who's coming?
Oh gosh, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
It's Mewka.
Woo!
Sure, what's up?
Why did you have to do the hand gesture with it?
You got fired.
Yeah, I'm the guy that got fired.
Yes, thank you.
You're not gonna let that go, huh?
She doesn't remember my name.
Fish want her.
Women scare her.
What's your name again?
Haito Kanda.
Haito.
Haito?
Minto.
Everybody remember my name.
I'm Minto.
I'm Mint.
I'm mint.
Minto.
They're back again.
I came to see you, Miyuka-chan!
Should I have not come?
I just ended up here.
I'm mint.
No, you're Murphy.
I don't care if you've got that silly wig on.
Are you sure?
Lock in.
Got it, pistachio.
Dang, messed up, sorry.
What do you...
I'm scared.
I feel like I'm coming off too strong if I say this.
Maybe should I not come?
Maybe I gotta be like, Did you not want to see me, Miyuka?
I don't know what she wants to hear.
Mint's kazoo covers?
Wait, where is my kazoo?
I have one actually.
No, I'm mint.
No, me!
Play hard to get.
Should I have not come?
No, it's not that.
You must be low on money though.
Don't worry, I gambled!
This is a collecting mission.
to charm all the girls.
We can't let the other customers have them.
Use codec 80.08.
Got it.
Colonel!
You're that curry ninja.
I'm helping out my friend now, so it's okay.
You don't have to worry about that.
I'm not worried.
Okay.
It's my turn to be Nint.
Never!
Unless I possess you.
Actually, I'm Mint.
No!
Oh, me!
You must spend your money wisely.
It's necessary to live.
Yeah, I'll make sure to do that.
All wifus are OSPs?
Thanks for coming here to spend that important money.
You're welcome.
Thanks for showing me...
I have a gift for her!
I feel strange to say you're welcome after that.
Why?
You smiled for me.
me again.
It's so creepy when we say that.
Oh, you still haven't had enough to drink.
Do you want to order anything else?
I too am also meant.
Oh my god, this face is the cutest.
What?
Should we try...
What's the other girl's name, Rin?
That's what you guys said?
Hmm...
Oh...
Yeah?
Okay, let's try her.
I'm gonna get something cheap.
Can I have a drink with you?
Sorry.
Thank you for all this over chat to you guys.
Thank you!
Looks like a customer is calling, so I better get going.
Bye-bye.
Miuka.
She's so cute.
Oh my gosh, wait, she's so cute.
She's so...
Sorry,
I got that gamer posture.
She called me cute.
Why are you curled up in a ball, sir?
What's wrong?
She's really cute.
You must be nervous.
That's no good.
Getting nervous over me is just a waste of energy.
Hello, my name is Haito Kanda.
It's a pleasure to meet your acquaintance.
That's hilarious.
You started introducing yourself.
I'm also...
Hello, I'm Rint.
I have a pepper in my throat.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm crying.
No.
Girls start coughing and straight up passed away.
Oh my god, hold on.
I'm going to go get some more water.
I think...
I'm so sorry, you guys.
Give me one second.
I'm so sorry.
I told you.
It's the Gyaru.
I can't deal with the reju!
I can't deal the reju!
I'm back, sorry about that.
I'm back with baby tomatoes.
Okay, Rin is actually trying to, um, actually trying to
Exercise my soul, but that's okay!
That's okay!
That's A-O-K.
Haichan.
What do you do, Haichan?
Right now, I'm assisting an acquaintance with their job.
Oh, my gosh.
You can't keep saying that you're such a mess up, my guy.
You can't stop saying...
Don't say a plethora...
Okay.
Until recently, I was employed at a company.
However, due to a plethora of mistakes, I was terminated.
That does not make you look good.
Why are you... Why are you saying that?
Why... This guy has the worst, like, elevator pitch ever.
I get her, though.
I get her so much.
Hang on, Hai-chan.
I can't keep up with all this.
that formal speech and be like super grateful if you could
just like talk normally boy failure so true oh really i'll
drop the pretences then thank you you're such a nice guy
hi-chan it's like their loss for firing you you're like way
better off with them she's so cute oh my gosh she's so cute
look at her look at her smug little face oh my gosh wait I
think I like Rin a lot no they treated me pretty well but
but I'm getting by okay now yeah
Wow you're really something high-chan like you won't even
bad them even after getting fired.
I respect that.
Yaru-Mint, my dreams come true.
What dreams are you having?
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna give her my macarons.
You're like a stand-up guy.
You must get that a lot, huh?
Let me hear some more.
What?
Who is they?
They do.
You must get that a lot.
They do what?
Who?
I want some more.
Oh yeah!
I want some more!
Let me hear some more.
You're such a kind, upstanding person, Haichan.
Like, you're such a good person.
Beepa!
Hey!
You're such a good, good, good, good, good.
Oh my god, I paid for this service.
So you know what?
It's...
You're such a kind, upstanding person, Haichan.
It's so true, you know, like, you're so kind and so
upstanding.
Like, how's that?
Oh,
hey, like, let me tell you something.
I'm serious.
Well, I'm always serious, but like, now I'm, like, serious.
seriously serious.
Southern Mint is still my favorite mint.
Meeting new people is really important, right?
So like in life, I mean, like, so I'm really grateful to
have like met you, Haichan.
Oh my gosh, she's so sweet.
I'm hook line and sunk.
Gosh, I've been fished by Rin.
I think so.
I may be far from perfect, but I'll still do the very best I
can.
I hope you're ready.
Oh my God, like how cute she is!
She's just a silly girl!
How embarrassing!
Wait, like, what am I saying?
I'm just like, so silly.
Well, you get the idea, right?
Did you catch all that?
Because I won't say it again.
Uke-er!
Oh my god, and she's even vouching for the other girls.
She's like the best.
She's a girl's girl.
She's an everybody's girl.
She's so great.
Focus on the prize.
You keep glancing at the other two girls.
I'm trying to decide, you know.
You know.
But it is kind of like one of those, like, when you see the
other girls, you're like, what am I missing out on, you
know.
Mm-hmm.
By the way, the other girls here are all really nice too.
I think you'll like this shop a lot.
If you find that I'm not your type after talking to me a few
times, feel free to sat...
Saddle?
Slide?
What does this mean?
Saido.
Up next to another girl instead.
Oh my gosh, she's so sweet.
I'm not the type of girl who's like bothered by that sort of
thing.
Well, on the other hand, if you do find that I'm your type,
it'd make me, like, pretty happy.
I don't know how I feel about her, like, rubbing her hands,
though, like, a bond villain.
Maybe she's a little more evil than we know, you know?
She's like, yes, yes.
Yes, by the bunny trap.
Yes.
I'm not the type to get upset about those things, but you
know you want to stick with me.
Yes.
She's scheming.
Well, I'll leave it at that for now.
With that said, I look forward to serving you.
Have you not had enough to drink, Kai-chan?
If you want some more, I can get you some.
Oh, yes.
You did it.
That was about to get so lonely.
She has the same embarrassed pervert smile as me.
What are you talking about?
What do I want?
The bunny trap, of course.
Wait, does it even matter what I...
Wait, so wait.
I guess it does matter what I order, because the more I
spend, the more they like me, right?
So...
So it's just an overall price.
Yeah, yeah.
This tastes so good.
She's so cute.
Let's give her the present.
If it's okay, would you be willing to accept this?
I hope you like it.
I got something?
I got something good.
Okay.
Can we Riz all three?
Can our wallet handle it?
I don't know.
Man, I'm really no good at this formal stuff.
I just can't do it.
What good is it anyway?
It's meant to show respect to the person you're speaking to.
I know.
Yeah,
I know that much, but you can still show respect without it,
right?
Oh my gosh, she messed up her words.
So cute.
I guess it's a way to easily convey that to respect the
person.
That's too on the nose.
I don't think that'd be necessary.
It'd be annoying for one thing.
Some people place a lot of importance on that sort of thing.
Can we get drunk in this game?
Oh, that's true.
I can't tell you how many times I've been snapped at.
You can?
Where's the drunk meter?
I guess I don't want to leave people with rotten feelings
either.
I've got no choice but to brush up on speaking more
formally.
Oh wait, this is good practice for me too.
The best way is to learn their experience.
I'll try it now.
Okay, let's start.
Are you doing well, Rin-chan?
Yes.
Do you enjoy this job?
Is she only just going to say hi to everything?
Yes.
Hi.
Do you like formal speech?
No.
Do you have any hobbies, Nin-chan?
Breathing.
Let's stop, Nin-chan.
You're fine the way you are now.
Wow, is it already this late?
I'm going to go back.
Oh, my gosh.
I think I'm leaving.
losing brain cells just talking to her.
Thank you, meantime.
Bye bye.
See you tomorrow.
Thanks for everything.
See you soon.
I'm motivated for what?
That's what I imagine that's like.
Oh, I didn't see them tomorrow.
Oh, I got paid a lot though.
Gambling time.
Come on.
Kamisama.
No!
Okay, one more.
One more.
We'll see.
I know I saved scum, but I want to have the belief that...
Wait.
The red eye.
That wasn't there before, right?
This is good, right?
This is good?
Oh.
We can win it back!
Campbelling buds.
This is it!
We'll win it all back and then some!
Yike!
I think...
I think we won it all back actually.
I don't think we made even a single Yenny back.
Oh, still down?
Okay, one more time, one more time.
5k short oh two two two eyes two eyes two eyes two eyes two
eyes
one more one more one more oh it's two eyes again i don't
trust it anymore
button?
Thanks, Joshua!
I like how whenever you're eating sometimes you sometimes
pout in and out, even during yesterday's stream.
It's so cute, like little chipmunk.
Or dare I even say it.
A bunny.
Stop it.
Stop watching me eat.
Okay, well, that's last one.
This is it!
Come on!
I
think we should reset the safe.
I think we should...
Oh no, no, no, I pressed...
I pressed... I pressed one more on accident!
I pressed... Instinctually instead of the...
Go back!
Uh-oh.
Oh god.
Well, it's okay.
We're gonna reload anyway.
Unless...
Ooh!
Not enough though.
Okay.
Most gamblers quit just before they win big.
I know.
What else can we buy?
Hmm.
I think she would like a necklace, but I'm not rich enough
yet.
To really...
Oh, perfume!
She would like that.
Motivation!
Oh god.
One dispatch consumes two days.
Be careful not to overwork and ruin your health.
Oh, okay.
We can get so much more!
Any hairstyle.
Inaba, inaba, inaba, take!
Just gamble more.
It wastes a day though, yeah, you're right.
No, no, it's not that much for just, for like.
Well, actually it's more than I, it's more than I made in a
whole week, but with just one day, right?
No, two days, it wastes a week.
Ah.
But then do I also get the money from my friend on top of
that?
Do I also get the...
Gambling looks more worth it.
Gambling is safer!
Oh wait, oh I made 500...
Wait, I made 57k?
Oh, just kidding.
Never mind.
Get out of here.
I can gamble.
The game says I can gamble.
Oh, I would have gambled.
We just once.
Just once, you guys.
Just once.
I'm praying on you.
Big boss.
Don't pray to God.
Pray to big boss.
You want to continue gambling?
Now I'm going to go spend lots of money on girls.
My time to spend money.
I mean, rest up and recover.
This is the only place that can heal my mind.
Cast members may be away on Saturdays.
Why not try having a conversation with other cast members?
Thanks, Rin-chan!
What do you mean, what?
I won big today!
We're getting...
Oh wait, if I get this...
I want that for her.
You're a simp.
Yeah, I am.
Thank you.
Simping for my bunny Oshi so she has funds to simp for other
bunny girls.
The circle of life!
Stop!
Yeah, get that for her.
Okay, I'll get the bunny trap again.
Of course, Din-chan!
Go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go.
Really?
Hooray!
I'll get the bottle!
This is like, so actually I've made cafes.
You can do stuff like this too.
And like a lot of cafes, like themed cafes in Japan, um,
like you can buy a champagne bottle and just like share with
the girls and stuff like that.
Sometimes you can, um,
I think sometimes you can even buy a bottle and just for the
girl to keep.
Like they don't, you don't even get to drink any of it.
Whoa!
That looks more than before, right?
Am I crazy?
That looks like the more, the more, the more, the more, the
more.
Lacey, a little bit.
I have a present for you!
If it's okay, would you be willing to accept this?
I hope you'll like it.
I'm glad you came back.
Thank you!
Like, have you been gut?
Yeah, you seem like you're in a good mood too, Nin-chan.
Brayden MC only, but...
What good would I be if I couldn't put on a smile?
You actually don't look like you're feeling so great
yourself.
Really?
I'm feeling fine physically today, and I don't have any
problems.
I'm not?
You're definitely not feeling good.
Not at all.
This is a bad omen, you know?
Get it?
Today's fortune!
Oh my god, she's an empath, yeah.
Oh my god, no way.
Not only is she scamming me, like, in the bar, but she's
also scamming me, she's a scamming fortune teller, too.
Oh my god, no!
Where is Kana?
It said she took the day off.
Mm-hmm.
On Saturdays, it said that they can sometimes take the day
off.
But hey, sir, you're lucky.
In fact, I can judge based on your name.
Wanna try?
Like fortune-telling with names?
Sure, I'll give it a try.
Okay, okay.
Uh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Mm-hmm.
Do you remember it?
I know your name already.
You're telling me.
what it was last time, right?
Yeah, I introduced myself to you.
I've had to do this before.
One time, one time I...
I met someone that I had met before.
But I couldn't remember their name.
And I had to write down their name for something.
And I was just like, oh, hi.
I'm taking everybody's names.
I just need to make sure it's spelled correctly.
Can you let me know how to spell it?
And they were like, it was like the most simple name ever.
I don't even remember.
It was like, like Mike or something.
They were like, Mike?
like oh yep
you know I could have been with like I don't know see like a
Q so I was like thank you I need to know how it's spelled to
do the fortune telling
do you spell your name in kanji oh she's at see you can get
away with that in japan right oh actually should we do kanda
or haito she likes to be formal i mean i'm not for she likes
to be um informal so mike
it's spelled in hiragana oh she might like that too because
she's dumb and she can't spell she can't write the kanji
spelled in hiragana no
way that my strategy is totally darn I read that this would
be a hundred percent foolproof first the characters for cup
and person then dry and field that's how you spell haito
kanda remember now cup and person so hi hi oh wait I was I
was thinking kan like kan like the kami sama kan and then da
is field yeah the the rice field cup person dry field
cup person you got me huh I like totally forgot your name
really sorry aw she looks sorry
You know, she tried.
Cuphead.
I found a way on mine to learn someone's name after you
forget it.
I set to offer to tell their fortune with it.
Clever, huh?
How did you figure it out?
Was I acting suspicious?
You seem like the type of person who can't tell a lie,
Rin-chan.
It was written all over your face and how you were acting.
I know.
People usually tell me they can read me like an open book.
Sorry,
I totally remember about how do you spell your name again?
Meant?
Meantos?
First with an M.
my arms.
Then with an I, I'm standing tall.
Then with an N, no other way.
Last is a T.
Take it away.
Mint.
You guys are still spelling it wrong.
Would you freestyle that?
I freestyle everything.
I'll live honestly.
It's like so tiring to cover things up with lies.
It's easier to just be honest and then apologize when you
get scolded.
I'm really sorry, Haichan.
You told me your name, but I forgot it.
And I tried to pull the wool over your eyes.
I'm really sorry.
It's all right.
It didn't bother me at all.
It just matter.
How am I supposed to be mad?
Made menthol star!
For real?
Like, yay!
Let's kick back and have some fun!
We'll go extra hard today to make up for my...
Make up for my scurrilla!
Tint!
No!
I said M like my arms!
Time totally flies when I'm with you, Haichan.
What shall we do?
Will you stay with me for a few more rounds?
Yes.
Yes!
Yo-cha!
Actually, actually, yo-cha.
Actually, yo-cha.
Yakuzao.
I think I've already spent a good amount of money, so I'm
gonna get a highball.
An elegant finish that cannot be found at other places.
Mid mic.
Stop!
Of course.
Um...
Wait, I already got this, right?
Yeah.
Um...
We're gonna...
We're gonna get you...
Let's get you the...
The bunny punch again.
Mmm, tasty!
Here we go.
Yeah, reach for it.
It's written like bint.
No!
What's the food?
Oh, edamame!
Oh my god, pizza.
Whoa!
Quality suit.
I feel like these should be switched, right?
Special parfait.
Hope you're enjoying your time with the spiciest yellow
bunny girl, Rin.
Minto!
Thank you!
Yes.
Pizza!
Additive free pizzas.
This place is fancy.
Assorted candies.
Salad.
Rich flavor.
Everything is...
A lot of potato flavor.
When she rubs her hands together, I can only see the guy in
the yellow suit behind the tree meme.
What's that one?
My kamiyoshi, Michael Phantom, That's not my name.
I want some French fries.
Obeyishii!
Yes!
Are you okay with ghosts?
What about you, Rin-chan?
Are you afraid of them?
Okay.
This?
Rin-chan, don't let me down.
Don't let me down, Rin-chan.
This is...
I know I am, thank you!
All-natural pizza fresh off the pizza tree.
Don't let me down.
Don't let me down, Bean.
Tascaru?
If one showed up in front of me, I'd smack it.
I guess I would.
Look at her face though.
Is
she...
I'm no afraid.
I'm not afraid of them.
Right?
People are just scared of them.
All they can do is startle you basically.
I guess it's time for my username to be...
To be relevant again.
Thanks Ghost Darker!
I can do way more than just startle you, Rin.
Have you ever seen a ghost before, Rin?
I haven't.
I wish one would show itself to me at least once.
Me!
I'm right here!
I'm right in front of you!
Wait, so she could smack me?
Yeah, maybe they're afraid of you because I think you're
gonna smack them.
The poor things, I just want to see one.
Yeah, bye now!
Maybe you'll meet one if you hang around abandoned buildings
or haunted spots.
Or, you know, like an abandoned maid cafe!
Why is chat spamming Bustin?
Am I missing something?
Are they?
To be honest, I didn't notice.
I thought you weren't afraid of ghosts.
Wobake is a weak one.
Woke?
Wake?
Weak!
Excuse me, weak!
Ghost is weak so they aren't scary.
But if a monster jumped out, I'd be terrified.
Not weak.
Abandoned buildings are dark and damp, you know?
Monsters like places like that.
They could pop out for sure Thought monsters and ghosts were
basically the same thing Oh, um, actually Oh,
actually Um, actually, um, actually not at all.
They're totally different.
I could never fight a monster.
Those guys seem tough.
They're huge with fangs and claws too risky
She's kind of cute when she's scared.
Oh, it's so scary.
That'd be awful if I thought about those monsters tonight.
Oh, do you need someone to...
I could be the...
She's going to think about me.
W, just like your arms.
plasm you're made of.
Hey, all of the simping.
Okay, the response this dono deserves.
Weak.
Weak, weak, weak.
If that happens, I'm blaming it on you, Haichan.
Next time I see you, I'll smack you.
Uh-huh.
Just kidding.
For free?
But you have fangs.
I have one fang.
Time to extend.
Let's continue.
All right, all right, all right.
I want something that's gonna...
Oh, depending on the person, it seems easy to become
intoxicated.
I want something that's gonna make me drunk.
Yeah.
What does she like?
I think I've spent a lot of money.
Does she like...
Like a lemon sour?
No, everybody likes a lemon sour, right?
Ghost are kind of weak, though.
Just hit him with like...
Oh, ow, stop it!
Rin's armpits.
She like the Bunny Punch a lot.
Get Rin drunk?
Oh, hey!
Oh, he see!
Drunk.
Yeah, girl, we're getting ready tonight.
We're partying!
Itadakimasu.
Itadakimasu!
Flat is best.
Flat is justice.
I...
I'm just... But, you know...
I'm not gonna be against anything.
I'm a...
I'm a bubba connoisseur.
This is bringing back trauma about having to explain my
overly specific knowledge and lingo use with
Let's talk.
What do you usually do when you're home alone, Rin-chan?
So you're an otaku too?
She's an otaku!
She's a keeper, everybody!
What?
Oh my god, best girl!
She's so good!
She's a gamer.
She's a... she's a anime enjoyer.
I usually watch anime and read manga.
Sometimes I play video games.
Isn't that about all there is to do?
Really?
I'm a bit surprised.
I thought you'd be more into girly stuff.
Gyalu-poy?
So true.
What do you mean girly stuff?
Gyalu stuff.
Doesn't everyone watch anime and read manga?
She's a keeper.
Oh!
She's so great.
Oh, she's so good.
Dean Chan!
I don't care if something's...
If something's girls or whatever.
I just do what I want to do.
You're right.
It's not good to make assumptions like that.
Sorry, Dean Chan.
Do you think Irene likes girls?
Asking for myself.
If she does, we're both in luck.
No, I'm sorry.
I shouldn't have said it like that.
I don't blame you for thinking I was mad at you.
She's so real.
This is the route meant.
I know, I know!
I didn't mean to sound like I was accusing you of anything.
To be honest, I like make assumptions about other people as
well.
What do you think about me?
She's got such good fashion sense.
I wish she was the blue character though.
Like you know, I wish she was wearing blue.
I'll think things like this guy seems serious.
He probably does this and that.
No, it's okay.
I'm pretty dumb huh I don't like it when people did smear
but like I still do it to others no one's perfect you got to
work it I love her hair she's so cute it's kind of like mine
maybe I should wear a side pony I'm kind of inspired right
now her hair is like mine just different colors but I'd
better stop Like, treat others like you'd want to be
treated.
That's what my grandma always said.
She was definitely right.
He's just like me.
The best way to stop is to learn more about other people.
So I'll start with you, Haight-chan.
By the way, what kind of person do you think I am?
Right now, you're like the kind of person who screwed up and
got fired?
No, I can't let myself make assumptions.
I need to fix my view.
That's not an assumption.
It's just the truth.
So no matter how much we get to know each other, It won't
change.
Wow, is it already this late?
I'm going to go back really sad and embarrassed.
Time to go home.
Thank you.
Bye-bye.
Thanks for everything.
I got to drink some delicious alcohol and have fun
conversations.
Now I'm motivated for work.
Sunday.
Hmm.
Oh, wait.
Oh, sorry.
Uh, this one.
Let's gamble it.
I'm wearing a gamble.
Oh, big boss.
Big boss.
Boss.
Thank you for your boss.
Thank you.
Boss.
Yeah, no, you guys.
I didn't save on purpose.
Because.
because this is real life, okay?
This is real life.
Keep rolling.
Okay, one more.
Just one more.
I wonder what the I sparklies mean.
If they mean anything.
Oh,
it's only 800 yen.
One more.
Give me the jackpot.
Please!
Oh god, I'm gonna lose my house!
Oh god, oh god, oh god!
Please, the jackpot!
Ah!
Better than nothing.
Okay, one more.
Oh god, I'm scared!
I can't look, I can't look!
Cha-ching!
What?
What are these tiny baby amounts?
I mean, not that I'm complaining or anything, but...
What?
One more!
Okay, end on a win.
This is the last one.
Last one, last one, last one, by the power of my bunny ears,
I manifest money into my wallet!
I think I missed...
Last, last one?
You guys, I don't think I can...
I don't think I can recover.
I actually don't think I can financially recover.
You're right.
I am.
This is what it's like when Arona gives you nine blues and
one yellow.
It's over.
It's over for me.
Who wanted to go see the bunny girls anyway?
Maybe that girl was wrong.
Maybe my life really is over.
Maybe.
Maybe I just should have...
Wow, wait, anyway.
What a crazy dream we saw right just then, wasn't it?
Oh, my God.
You guys, I just had the craziest dream.
I'm so glad I woke up from that.
I just kept gambling and losing and losing and losing.
This is why I quit sports, but...
Oh gosh Anyway I shaved, brushed my teeth and got the
wrinkles out of my clothes I'm good, let's go into this shop
I'm all dressed up fancy for them Hello, Min-chan Of course
What do you think?
um what should we have minchan i lost a lot today so
okay and also i won't save scum every time you guys don't
worry don't worry that's why i took the first loss you know
i'm gonna have a vintage umesh i'm gonna get wasted today
Because I lost a lot of money.
Um, yeah, do you want to...
Uh...
Um...
Do you want... Here, you know what?
Let's have the same thing!
Yeah!
Mm-hmm!
Mm-hmm, oh!
I like it here.
Itadakimasu!
I don't have a present for her or anything.
Let's just talk.
What do you do on your days off, Dine-chan?
Wait.
You asking me on a date?
You're like pretty aggressive, huh, Hai-chan?
That's not what I meant!
I really am interested.
Oh, I think you're very charming.
I wouldn't come and see you if I didn't.
It's funny that you think that.
It's so funny that it's actually a little embarrassing.
Oh my gosh, she's so cute.
Thanks, though.
Anyway, you wanted to know about my days off.
Let's spin this around.
What do you think I do?
Oh, okay, I have to judge her.
I think...
Okay, she said that she watches anime and she plays games,
so maybe spend time.
Okay, either shopping for clothes or spend time at home,
right?
Right?
I think she spends time.
Spend time at home.
Oh, you're right!
That's pretty much it lately.
I've got like a stack of manga and this season's anime to
catch up on.
She's so real.
I love her!
She also goes to carry karaoke by herself?
I like went to karaoke in front of the station by myself
last weekend.
I sang nothing with the songs that I wanted to sing myself.
She's just like me!
I guess you try to pick the songs that everyone knows when
you go with friends.
Literally me, I am also very cute.
I believe you.
Yeah, I like hearing people sing but like going with friends
is fun too oh wait so going with friends is fun too but like
last weekend i wanted to sing and blow off steam just like
me forever what were you doing last weekend hi-chan were you
making up with girls maybe uh no i was here obviously not i
don't even know anyone who'd want to.
Don't say that!
Hi, doll!
Oh,
yeah.
Well, then,
why don't I act as your partner?
Here.
I'll blow a kiss to you.
Maha!
That's all for now.
So hang in there, okay?
Is this what it feels like to go to the afterlife one more
time?
It's been so long since I knew what it felt like to die.
Sayonara, sweet world.
Umeshu?
Yeah, let's get some more umeshu.
Have you not had enough to drink?
Look at her face.
She's so cute.
My goodness.
If you want some more, I can get you some.
Yes.
That's good.
Umeshu for me?
Umeshu for you?
Do you believe in life after after life?
Do you believe in life after life?
Itadakimasu.
Should we get something to eat?
I love having...
Where's the mixed nuts?
Izakaya or not Izakaya bars always have like the nuts that
you can have right um give more fries pizza it's expensive
pizza she likes pizza she does I mean who doesn't like pizza
okay well we're not spending so much money today we just
lost a lot of money so why not
This is my favorite, so yummy!
Really?
Hi, I'm...
Have you got anything you want to do?
You want to do?
I hate pizza, actually.
What?
Why?
Why do you hate pizza?
Yeah.
having fun, Hai-chan.
Is there something you want to do?
I'll listen if there's anything you want to talk about.
Don't hold back.
Mint's streams have taught me that compulsive gambling and
good alcohol is the real way to a woman's heart.
Thanks, Mint.
I'll take this knowledge to heart.
I'm here to help you learn.
You're being pretty assertive today, Rin-chan.
What's going on?
She's drunk!
I thought I should try harder to starve my customer...
Well, serve.
Sorry.
Sorry if I read it wrong.
I thought I should try harder to serve my customers well.
That's what they call good service.
No?
She's so awesome.
She cares about me, you guys.
I'm not parasocial.
She cares about me.
I mean, think about it.
You're spending your own hard-earned money to talk to me.
Oh,
she's so good.
She cares about me.
It's money, money, money that's valued equally all over the
world.
I know I'm a stupid.
And you're using that money to come see me, right?
Are you actually trying to tell us something, Mint?
Is your maid cafe actually a place to starve customers to
turn you into a wist?
No!
Why would you think that?
It's pretty crazy, right?
I can't just half-ass things now that I've realized how far
people are willing to go for me.
I know I've bought her macarons, I've bought her perfume.
today but to be honest I prefer your usual style of service
Dean Chan what is going on money starve me boss no are you
kidding my usual style is just me like goofing off I've
never even been consciously providing service until now this
pose is so goofy
I can't just accept a paycheck for doing that, can I?
I need to make sure that I'm entertaining you too, not just
myself.
Hey, if you're having fun, then I'm having fun too.
In fact, it wouldn't be as fun for me if you just started
fussing over me.
True, it's not easy to relax when someone's fussing over
you, huh?
I'm gonna buy her a big present
Well, should I just act normal then?
That'd be easier, more fun for me too.
Sure, I like you best when you act like you usually do,
Nin-chan.
You're plenty charming just the way you are, okay?
We got some good points.
Yeah, yeah, we're pretty cool.
She's so cute.
That's embarrassing.
Don't say that with such a straight face.
I hope you'll be able to look you in the eye.
Oh, she's so cute.
It's Starbus.
I want to become an internal customer.
Yeah.
Oh, I'm not moody.
No, I'm not moody.
No, anything.
Yeah.
Let's have...
What's her favorite, I wonder?
We're gonna get drunk drunk.
Bleshingiarus are very effective.
Thank you!
I'm being fed so well tonight.
Have you realized you can control the camera when she
reaches for your drink?
There's a zoom?
Oh, I didn't know when he told me this before.
Huh?
Wait, is this real?
Do you have a phone?
Hi-chan, are there any apps you spend a lot of time on?
Oh, you got games on your phone?
But I don't gamble or anything.
It's real?
We've been telling you?
I haven't seen!
What do you mean we've been telling you?
I'm playing the game!
You mean like, are there any games or anything I'd
recommend?
Yeah, but I don't need any more games.
I still have my daily routine.
do more.
Something other than games, huh?
Oh, wait, man.
Wait, I have that?
A map app?
Doesn't every phone have that?
A photo editing app.
She might like that, right?
Mmm.
The day alias.
I don't know.
She might like this, though.
Photo editing app.
She's like not into the typical things a gyar would be into.
You know when you like think of a gyar.
It's just like shopping and makeup and everything like that.
Like I mean I'm sure she's into it but like you know they
are always heavily editing their stuff.
Yeah no riz.
A lot of people use this when they take selfies.
I tried using one once but it was a pain to use to give up.
It's okay, I'll buy her another pizza.
Hai-Tan, did you know people back in the day didn't have
phones at all?
Isn't that crazy?
I don't think I could survive if I didn't have my phone.
Yeah, me too.
Once you get used to having one, you just can't give it up.
She's so cute.
Exactly.
Maybe once I get used to me, you won't be able to give me up
either?
If I get too into you, I might just want to keep you out of
my...
Haido!
Are we... We're like zero.
Seriously, flirting, aren't we?
Why don't you then?
In fact, you should.
Make it so you can't live without me.
Yeah, that'd be great!
So from now on, keep getting more and more hooked on me,
okay?
I'll do my best too!
Here, I love you!
I love you, Hai-chan!
Muah, muah!
Come see me more!
Wow, is it already this?
No, Hai-chan!
No, you were in!
Don't go!
You idiot!
Thanks for today.
Bye-bye!
I can't believe it.
I'm motivated for work.
I don't
know.
Oh, 700 yen.
It's better than losing!
I mean, it's technically a win.
Hold on.
What stuff do we have?
here nothing has changed yet I think it's time to buy her
the bouquet of roses the bouquet of or yeah the book well
maybe she should she probably like snacks the pajamas she
probably would like pajamas a lot right seven dollars is
seven dollars exactly because
she likes to stay at home right okay if I win this next one
I'll buyer the pyjamas pyjamas pyjamas pyjamas pyjamas
pyjamas pyjamas pyjamas pyjamas
why does this keep happening to me you guys oh that is such
a big amount of money load
Crazy dream
Anyway I'm buying her pajamas
We gotta get in I shaved, brushed my teeth and got the
wrinkles out of my clothes Let's go into the shop
She's here, thank goodness Thank you for that, you're so
happy to see you Yeah!
Our usual...
Well, I'll get the umeshu.
I don't think...
Me even getting drunk, maybe she's more like, like, you
know, love you with me if I'm if we're drunk, you know?
Maybe we take more risks too because we get drunk, right?
But I think we're gonna give her the bunny punch.
It's like, I pay so much more and I still get the same show.
Itadakimasu.
Pajamas made out of 100% cotton.
I have this for you.
If it's okay, would you be willing to accept this?
Oh, the e!
I forgot!
I'll get it next time.
Sorry, guys.
Are you hooked on me, Hai-chan?
Am I your favorite?
Sorry, I'll get the bit- I'll- I gotta get the big bottle
and zoom in, you know?
What makes you think that?
It's not like I bought you like so many presents or
anything.
I mean, I'm not- I mean, I'm not- I mean, if I'm not- I
don't know how to do it, I'm not- I- You've been coming to
see me pretty often.
I'm sorry if I got the wrong idea.
It's a bit embarrassing.
You don't have the wrong idea.
I enjoy talking to you, Lin-chan.
Be honest, yeah.
In that case, can you remember what we've talked about?
Oh, I can't.
You know, I was just talking to you about.
You know, I was just talking about that.
You know, I can't.
because i'm obsessed with you like we chatted about what i
do on my days off right you can't remember all the little
details can you oh combine words while remembering previous
conversation women don't like men who don't remember um you
karaoke sorry kraoki kraoki kraoki by herself by herself
with her cat that'd be awesome kraoki in front of the
station Jeopardy!
Good.
You guys, we did good.
We did good.
You really did remember?
Wow, that's crazy.
I'm like so genuinely happy.
What should I do?
Wow,
was I acting kind of clinging just now?
Like asking if I'm your babe?
And about past conversations?
We're going in.
Yeah, let's go to Kraoki with Lin-chan.
I really didn't mean it like that at all.
But I can't help it if you think I'm cringe.
and too self-conscious.
Nya, cringe.
I don't think of you that way at all.
Are you sure you should be saying that?
I get carried away sometimes, you know.
If I wasn't okay with that, I wouldn't come to visit you,
Nin-chan.
Oh, no, you're okay.
So, Hi-chan will I make it to my own opinion
She doesn't say that to everybody, you guys.
She's only saying that to me.
She only said that to me.
She's- I'm her favorite now!
In that case, I'll make you my favorite too.
So you'd better keep coming to see me, okay?
Where's- oh, where?
Where?
Of course.
Oh dang, time like totally flies when I'm with you,
Hai-chan.
What should we do?
Will you stay with me for a few more rounds?
I'm so whipped.
Let's continue.
I'm gonna get...
Okay, I'm gonna get something cheap for me.
We're gonna get the U-Lang Heibol.
Because we're gonna get the bottle.
for her.
Easy to get drunk.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cheap for me.
I know the zoom.
That's why I'm getting the bottle.
Of course.
Okay, here we go.
Zoom.
Oh.
How do I go down?
Oh, wait.
Ah!
Control, control, control!
Yeah!
Automatically sooner.
Just a glimpse.
I'm teasing you guys, I'm teasing you guys.
Oh,
I want to go on vacation!
Wait, is she gonna invite me?
That sounds nice.
Where would you want to go?
A hot spring or maybe somewhere overseas?
Seychee june leikana?
You guys, she's so perfect.
I'm going to go to, like, a nerd-pring pilgrimage.
I could visit places that inspired settings in anime and
manga.
She's so good.
Yeah, I've heard of that sort of thing.
Some small towns have been revitalized because of it, right?
Perfect for real.
I'm sorry.
I shouldn't I misjudged her so much.
She's so perfect.
She's so good.
In some places, the producers and local governments
cooperate for collaboration events and stuff.
I really want to go.
Will you come with me, Hai-chan?
I'm interested, but it won't be as fun if I don't know the
anime, will it?
You gotta take her to Hinami-zawa.
Oh my gosh.
Bean-chan with Hinami-zama syndrome?
Oh la la.
In that case, I'll enjoy the anime collabs and you can
enjoy...
What's that mean?
What do you mean by that?
What do you mean?
Enjoy you.
Like, you can enjoy looking at my smiling
while I eat yummy food, and you can feel my excitement while
I buy all the anime merch.
Oh, so that's what you meant.
Going on a trip with you sounds like a lot of fun, Ninjan.
Oh, were you thinking that I meant something naughty?
I guess you would imagine that if we were traveling alone.
No, I didn't.
I was picturing a normal, wholesome trip.
Really?
In that case, I feel kind of defeated.
Calls for more celebration.
Well, we need to...
to get to know each other better before we go on a trip
let's put the idea on hold for now take her to uji and go
sit on the kumiko bench
me i'm an otaku but you know i really wish i had someone to
enjoy otaku stuff with it's fun by my myself but it'd be
even better to share it with someone I'm here isn't there
anyone out there anyone who understands my hobbies and will
enjoy it with me oh my god she's playing with my heart you
guys need Rin lot wife so true so true she's so perfect
let's battle again let's just go for that omai show again
Rin was born for mint.
She's just like me.
Oh, oh,
sorry.
I clicked out of the game on accident.
It's so despised.
I like the sound effect that it makes.
I'm going to get demonetized.
conversation.
It really was on accident!
We can't do it anymore.
I just can't, please, Haichan.
What can't you handle?
A new anime, a special version of En-vain.
I want to see.
There's a special audio commentary on that.
I know.
Not that I can't.
It's a special edition release of a new anime out.
I want it!
It's got audio commentary from the director as a bonus.
I see.
Well, if you want it that badly, why don't you buy it?
Because I already have the regular edition.
I don't want to buy it again just for the bonus feature.
Nin-chan, are you a novice otaku or what?
Everybody knows that you buy at least three copies of the
things that you love.
Especially, especially for the bonus!
Nin-chan, this is real.
Yeah, I think we can buy it for her, though, right?
From the little rabbit shop?
But I'm not the type of girl who can just grin and bear it.
If there's something at what, I can't stop thinking about
it.
Are you like that too, Hai-chan, or can you hold back?
I beg my parents to pay for it?
No, I can't hold back.
I can't hold back.
Wait!
Uh-oh.
She didn't like it.
We have no Riz.
I just wanted to be relatable to her.
Oh no!
No.
Oopsie.
Is this really the best answer to a hostess?
I-it's the best answer, I feel.
Because if, say, she is my fixation, then I'm always going
to be spending on her.
Right?
I think?
That's not how that works.
Anyway.
I knew it.
I think people who can, who can are really amazing.
But if you don't hold back sometimes, you'll be broke in no
time.
She's seeing how weak-willed I am.
You're right.
I've decided.
I'll hold back for now.
I've already have the normal edition.
I won't waste my money.
Oh, I guess you can hold back after all, huh?
I'll at least wait until it goes on sale.
Once it does, I might crack.
She wants a financially responsible man.
You're right, you're right.
really bad I really am bad at holding myself back like that
not just with physical things either what else oh my god I
can't wait for the arc when Rin shows up at my house at 3 a
.m like if I had someone I liked even if they were super far
away if I wanted to see them I'd like go right away Even
late at night.
That's amazing.
Have you ever done anything like that before?
No.
But I'm sure it's the sort of thing I do.
I guess you're the type who really devotes themselves to
people, huh?
Oh, well, not exactly.
I wouldn't go unless I really wanted to see them.
I don't know.
She's so cute.
Like, thinking about it that way, I guess I'm kind of a pain
in the butt.
If you bother me, it'd probably be tough for you too, you
know?
Oh, it's getting wet!
Haito just leaves.
And like, the best part...
Fighting town.
This guy.
I can't stand him.
I'm motivated.
Sunday.
Didn't you guys say that the gambling seems safer?
It's safer!
Oh my gosh, you guys, we did it!
We can't vacation yet.
Look how cute she is, though.
Yes, yes, yes.
They're all cute.
But Ninjan.
Ninjan now.
They don't have it yet.
Let's get her some socks.
Oh, yeah, let's save too.
Okay.
Let's go!
Now is my time to rest and recover.
This is the only place that can heal my mind.
Healing my mind.
Hello.
When do we get to like... I've seen...
I've seen some stuff where like you can take pictures.
I mean, obviously there's the album.
When do I get taking... when do I get to take pictures with
you?
Alright, thanks for the time gift.
Thank you.
Okay, bunny patch.
Mmm.
Checkies are first, if I remember correctly.
Okay.
Should be soon.
Oh!
I forgot about those.
Zoom.
My bad.
I'll give you.
Asa Masisa.
Mm-mm-mm.
Picture time is when Rin decides it's picture time.
So true, she can do whatever she wants.
You know blood type personality theory?
That stuff's so ridiculous.
Do you believe in it?
I never thought that deeply about it before.
Like, you're type A, so you're very methodical.
It's so dumb.
There's millions of people with type A.
They aren't all the same.
Oh, I wonder, is it some kind of trend?
It makes sense, though.
Going along with that trend, what type do you think I am?
Go on, guess!
Wait, I don't know blood types at all.
Uh...
Um...
Oh, it's rare, right?
So...
Hmm...
Oh?
Don't call her A.
Yeah, I don't think calling her A would be good, right?
I do wonder, though.
Um.
I do wonder if, like, how badly you can mess up with these
girls.
Once I, like, play the game, I want to, like, do a fail run
where I, like, I'm so, so bad with them.
Okay.
Let's try Type O.
Oh.
She doesn't want to be called type O.
Isn't that like the rare one that people really want to be?
What were type O supposed to be again?
Layed back or something?
Well, I guess it's true that I don't sweat the small stuff.
B-gata.
Oh, really?
Oh, it can donate to anyone.
Oh, it was the most common.
What is?
Mmm, I'm like it.
I'm like it.
Yeah, it wasn't even an option.
Maybe she wanted to be called type A because she says she's
methodical.
So maybe she wanted us to also see that she's methodical.
Do you guys know your blood type?
Actually, I will, I don't have blood, but I don't even know
what I would be.
I don't think, I don't think I ever was told before.
Hmm.
Don't.
Mine is O.
O?
O plus.
I'm O plus.
I think I'm A.
What ectoplasm type are you?
Probably E.
It's like I've got the personality traits of all the blood
types.
So blood type personality theory isn't reliable at all.
I think more than a few people would agree if you put it to
them like that.
True.
They say that type A's, oh, I'm sorry to get silly.
And type B's aren't compatible, right?
But my little brother and sister are type A, and we get
along great.
What's your blood type, Hai-chan?
I'm type O.
There's no way.
this many of you were type O.
E, yeah I'm type E.
How compatible were type B and type O supposed to be again?
You don't believe in it, but you're still curious?
I like this face a lot.
I was just wondering about how compatible we are.
It's just on my mind a bit.
That's all.
I don't believe in it much, but if the two of us were
compatible, it'd make me happy.
Why is this game making me feel things?
Extend.
She's making... She's just so cute!
She's just so cute!
What did I get for her before?
I don't remember.
You know what?
Let's try...
Let's try a wine for both of us.
Wine, wine, wine.
I should probably try all the drinks, right?
She likes it too, though.
Good, good.
In Japan, A is most common.
Oh, really?
I didn't even see a single bit.
Wow, fancy wine.
I want to get better gaming.
I'm so sick of losing.
It's been stressing me out.
According to the NHS, people are O plus 35, O minus 13, A
plus 30, A minus 8, B plus 8, minus 2.
AB plus 2% AB minus 1.
Wow.
I always thought that O was the most rare, but I guess it's
because it's, uh, it's, maybe I was just thinking of it
being, um, compatible with, like, if you're O type, you can
give blood to anybody, right?
Ah, I know what you mean.
Competitive games are fun, but losing too much can be a
bummer.
Hi Chen, I don't want to lose anymore.
How can I get better at video games?
Try it.
Oh, gosh.
Um, cheap tricks.
I think if I tell her to get good, she'll be upset.
Right?
I don't know.
Get good, get good.
Okay, we'll tell her to get good.
You just gotta practice.
Why do I listen to you guys?
You don't understand the way to a girl's heart at all.
Oh my gosh.
I knew it.
It's like that with everything, not just games.
The only way to get stronger is work hard.
Oh my gosh, that's like so many responses in a row that we
haven't gotten any hearts on, you guys.
What games do you play, Rin-chan?
Oh, I mean, have you ever heard of a simple game series?
It's like kind of popular, but, you know, of it because
you're gamer and all.
Do you think she plays Valorant?
Because losing can get stressful, I've had some problems.
Problems?
Sometimes when I lose, I scream.
I scream.
Like, oh, or...
No!
She's got the gamer rage.
If I keep losing like this, I'll get kicked out of my house
for making too much noise.
That's certainly a big problem.
You'd better turn your losing streak around soon.
She should be a VTuber.
It's true.
No, she's cute.
She's too cute though.
You know?
She should be an actual streamer.
Not a VTuber.
Oh, but hang on.
Even if I win, I might still yell out loud.
Yata!
Oh yeah!
Or, take that, suckers!
VTubers are cute.
VTubers are cute too?
I mean, but like...
But like...
Isn't it nicer that us ugly people can become VTubers too?
And then when all the attractive people, you know, there's
like some VTubers that also like show their faces and stuff.
Must be nice, huh?
Must be nice to be a cute anime girl and also be able to
turn into a cute human.
Must be nice.
Nice.
But honestly, I don't mind.
Because as long as I get to look at cute things, I don't
care how I look.
I don't care how I look as long as I get to look at cute
things.
Maybe it'd be better if you soundproofed your room.
Oh, sake.
What do we not try?
I wonder if she's kind of weirdo.
Does she like the bunny mask?
Here, I'll just get my... I'll get a beer.
Or maybe she'll... Here, let's try a beer.
Actually, no, I want to try the Bunny Max.
Oh, she likes it!
But not like, liked it, liked it.
Choo-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-y!
Itadakimasu!
Um, okay, come for that.
Hi-chan-wa...
I keep making a bit of an assumption like you like me how
but you keep coming to see me so at least you don't hate me
right hey Mint are you winning so far I don't know actually
I can't tell I think she likes me though right I think she
likes me though right of course I don't hate you but if you
ask me which part of you I like which
part is a coco which part is cocoa which part is cocoa which
part do you mean cocoa get a good luck here or maybe here
maybe you like this part I don't know
She's so cute!
What's wrong?
Are you embarrassed?
Doesn't that seem backwards?
I'm the one who's embarrassed.
Cocoa's cute!
Hurry up and answer!
Where do you like?
What part of me do you like?
Oh, your personality!
You keep your guard down so it's easy to talk to you,
Rinchan.
I'm asking you, which part of me is sexy?
This part or here, but you're saying you like my
personality?
She seems kind of upset.
I'm passing
away.
She's so cute.
This is no fair.
I'm really starting to feel embarrassed.
How did you turn the situation around like that?
W-Riz?
Still made me happy.
So you hang out with me because you like my personality.
When it gets away.
Time to go.
Oh, Hayato, you dummy, dummy, dumb, dumb, dummy, dumb.
See you soon.
Motivated.
Motivation up.
I hope I get a bonus.
Give me more money so I can spend it on her.
Oh, Hatta.
This guy.
I has like zero Riz for real.
He is so funny.
It's like right as it's starting to get steamy, he's like,
got a dip.
Oh my god.
The money.
I mean, we got the money.
We won.
Oh, oh shit.
Why did I say yes again?
I'm such a idiot.
I meant to exit out.
accident.
Rich.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Yata.
You think she would want a wristwatch?
Hmm.
Or some more macarons because they're delicious.
Hot dog!
There's also the makeup set.
Hmm.
Rin starts to lean into Haito and he high tails it.
He's just like me for real for real.
For real.
One more?
The luxury bag.
Oh my god, I'll have no money.
I'll have no money.
Pajamas, I already got her that.
She likes toys, so like plushies, right?
Let's get her the plushie.
It's cute.
Shun Tsui, thank you for the gift.
Thank you.
What should I drink today?
Beer, wine, champagne?
Let's just get in there first.
Oh!
Kaid.
Chat froze?
Oh, let me see if I can fix it.
There you guys are.
It's her day off, you guys.
It's her day off.
Give me the cash, sis.
Actually, I'll get the oolong highball.
You can get the cash.
Actually, no.
Wait, I wanted to go home.
I wanted to go home.
I should have...
I should have just bought the drink for her and then didn't
extend my time.
I'm wasting my money, guys.
Oh well.
What do you like to do on your days off?
She's cute though.
That sounds nice.
Is there a big age gap between you and your sister?
Oh, she likes to go to the park with her sister is what she
said.
Oh, she's still a second grader in elementary school.
Wow, that's a big difference.
What kind of games do you play with your sister?
Hide and seek.
Ah, you must be, you two must be close.
Because I'm the only one.
What do you mean by that?
Oh, what do you mean by that?
I think, I think Miyuka's trauma dumping on me.
Just a little bit.
No.
I mean, I guess I kind of asked, right?
But my parents died in an accident.
I'm the only one my little sister Moika has.
I didn't know.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
Yeah, it's okay.
Is it hard living together just the two of you?
I don't...
Maybe they're not lonely.
I don't want to say that.
Is it hard living?
Yeah,
more so for Moika than I.
I feel so sorry for her.
I can help you.
What do you mean by that?
You're the foundation.
So you're the foundation of her life.
What?
Ducky, thanks for the gifted!
Andrew goes, thanks for the 10 gifted!
Yes, there's no one else I can turn to.
That's unbelievable.
I admire you for doing that.
It's not unbelievable.
I just live.
The two of us.
Um, I think the vibes have been...
Ruby, thank you for the pipe, gifted!
Um...
See ya!
See ya later!
Bye bye!
Thanks for everything!
Oh, they don't see me out the door because I didn't spend
enough money.
Okay, ninja!
Min-chan!
I feel bad now though.
Don't worry about it.
Drink to forget it.
We're just, uh...
We're just getting rich, baby!
Yeah!
Oh man.
I'm gonna buy her a good bottle.
I'm gonna buy her the bottle.
Get me a special highball.
Of course.
Let's get her the big shampoo.
So if I get this really expensive one, is her skirt just
gonna fly off?
Is it just gonna go, is it gonna like tear into a thousand?
in pieces she's gonna be like yeah and I'm just like oh oh
this is what money can buy you know I wonder I'm gonna get
her easy to get drug from it
okay whoa today they're super they're super
Zebra print!
I didn't expect the zebra print.
Here's the dozo.
You liked it!
I'm so happy about this!
Do you have any siblings, Hai-chan?
Nope, I'm an only child.
What did you say to her?
Why is she suddenly asking about if I have siblings, huh?
After I talked to you yesterday, Muka, about your sibling.
What did you tell her?
You kind of give off an older brother vibe.
So I thought you must have a little brother or sister.
As for me, oh yeah, I mentioned it earlier, back when we
were talking about blood types.
Wait, what did she say?
Oh!
They're A-type, they're A-type.
Do you remember Hi-chan?
I'll be impressed if you remember my family members' blood
types.
Um, younger brother,
sister are both A.
Wow,
you like actually remembered?
What should I do?
How about a kiss on the cheek as a reward?
Good.
I have a little brothers and sisters who are way younger
than me.
They're both super cute.
Whenever I visit my parents, they cling to me and call me
big sis, big sis.
They literally wrap themselves around my legs.
Toots adorbs, huh?
We are so in.
Oh my gosh, she's scared.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Is this?
She's, I mean, she's talking about her family.
That's basically like meeting her family, you know?
We're already on that level.
Oh my gosh.
Are you so reliable because you're an older sister,
Nin-chan?
You think I'm reliable?
Really?
That's how you think of me?
I think I'm blushing.
But compared to me, Mioka's definitely more of a reliable
big sister.
Mioka, one of the cast members here?
Yeah, we're, we're like basically married.
Oh my gosh.
I'm...
I'm ready.
Children!
She also has a much younger sister, but they live together.
She looks after her too.
She's amazing!
I mean, don't I don't mean to compare us, but there's a lot
of things I'm not so reliable at, you know?
Like I spoil my younger siblings way too much for them all
the time.
We have a wife.
I'm so proud of us, you guys.
I'm so proud of us.
We're going to grow old with Nin-Chain.
I'm going to be like that guy that married Hatsune Miku.
Just going to put Nin-Chain on an iPad.
Ah, talking about them is making me miss them.
I'll call when I go home.
Oh, they'll be asleep in the morning then.
Oh, that's extend.
I guess it doesn't really matter what I buy.
Let's get some fine wine.
What do you like?
What's your favorite thing?
Is it this yomand?
I don't know.
Don't forget the present.
I already gave it to her.
I'm going to get the bunny punch since...
I mean, I could get the Lab Perry.
Everyone loves the yo-manned.
Oh my god, I almost accidentally pressed decision on this
one.
She liked the champagne a lot.
Yeah, look at her staring at me so patiently waiting for me
to make a decision.
See if it'll let you get...
No, I don't have enough money.
I don't have enough money for the Yomairon.
You know what?
Go big or go home.
We're getting paid soon anyway, so whatever.
It doesn't matter!
Itadakimasu!
Okay.
Oh, yes.
I can't give her any...
Okay, yeah.
Oh, can you draw it all?
Like, illustrations?
Not very well.
Why do you ask?
I'll write the story and you can do the drawings.
Let's become a manga author tag team.
What do you say?
Can you write, Bin-chan?
Once upon a time, in a certain land, there was a father, I
mean, a mother and a father.
That sounds like the opening to a folktale.
Doesn't that sound more like a picture book than a manga?
A picture book author home, that's good work too.
make my little brother and sister really yummy every time
she sticks her finger up like that it makes me just want to
talk like a nerd that's like the very beginning of the story
but i can't but i can't come up with anything past that i
guess i'm just not cut out for it i wish i was more
creative.
When you read manga and stuff, do you ever think, man, I
wish I could write something this good.
I did when I was a kid.
I wanted to be a manga author or a film director.
Same.
I can't help envy people like that.
I wonder if I can write something too.
Maybe if it's a game genre I'm good at.
Haichan, can you draw sexy girls?
Sorry, but I don't think I can draw much of anything at all.
Maybe I should use you as a reference then I could get
better at...
Come on, Haito, say it.
Haito, say it.
Let's get something else to drink.
I'm starting to actually get a bit of a headache.
So this might be my last day, but I'm so sad.
I wanted to get more stuff.
I wanted to unlock the vacations.
but next time maybe so let's get to the end of this night
let's drink um i'm gonna have a simple beer i'm a simple man
and i'll get you
what did she like uh the high ball the umeshu
i like seeing just a tiny bit of cheeks right it's kind of
cute hi John are you hiding something from me no I don't
think so why do you ask draw me like your French girls mint
don't you find it hard to keep secrets like that I'm no good
at it people tell me that my face makes it super obvious.
I've tried planning surprise parties for friends and family
members, but it's never worked.
They always figure it out.
She knows I'm a VTuber.
She knows that I'm streaming this.
Are you good at keeping secrets, Hai Chang?
I have nothing to hide.
Oh my god, we got a good reaction out of her.
You can't be serious.
Nothing at all?
You just lay everything out bare, huh?
That's amazing.
I lay it all out, everybody.
I'm not good at keeping secrets, but I usually can't tell if
someone's hiding something from me You mean you don't notice
when someone lies to you?
The wall's been pulled over my eyes more than a few times.
It sucks Like what the heck?
When I try to lie, they figure it out right away.
It's not fair.
This whole world is so unfair.
She has toggles.
Oh, so-de-shoe.
Well, I don't really like people who lie a lot anyway.
I much prefer honest people like you, Rin-chan.
If you say so, then I guess it's fine.
Oh, it's getting late.
I'm sorry, I'm going to go home.
Holy moly.
I am broke.
This checks out.
You started the game telling everyone you just got fired.
That's so true.
Thank you for today.
Energy.
Motivation.
Money.
Oh my gosh.
It's already June.
Nice.
We didn't even lose that much money.
money save scum for the big bottle yeah we'll have to get
the big bottle actually let's do gambling one more time
gamble gamble gamble come on guys come on pray pray pray
pray for us pray for us pray what
you guys prayed this is because of you what's the most that
you guys have I've seen someone win in the gambling.
What's the most you've seen that someone has won?
That was awesome.
Yippee!
Didn't know you were playing this game, I'll have to watch
the archive.
Yeah!
It's been fun, it's been a lot of fun.
40k, wow.
Oyasumi minto.
I got 26k earlier.
70k?
No way.
125k?
Are you lying?
What happens if you...
Well, I guess if you go broke, you have to work...
You have to do the dispatch and sleep, right?
Your overworked body.
No, we've been playing it safe, though.
So...
Maybe we gotta go bigger on the gifts, right?
Maybe I gotta get the luxury bag so that she'll love me and
let me take pictures of her.
I don't know, but we'll figure it out next time.
How long is this game, I wonder?
I'm so...
I feel like there's so much that I haven't seen yet.
But we'll play it next time.
Yes, yes, yes.
Go big or go home.
Um, Alta Minto, everyone, sorry for leaving a little bit
early.
campaign so i'm gonna go to sleep uh tomorrow what am i
doing tomorrow tomorrow i am your thank you rabbit house
from gucci uso is much different than i remember thanks for
the stream also 200k soon soon maybe we'll see we'll see
actually i noticed that like so many of my followers on on
on twitter like i lost so many followers it was like it's
like 10 000 i was i was wondering i was like oh my gosh did
i get canceled or something why is it why but i guess maybe
it's bots oh tomorrow i'm doing mahjong yeah mahjong
tomorrow so i'll do my best hopefully my brain won't be too
empty but uh we shall see but i want blue archive so Mmm,
mmm, mmm.
Minto.
Mint cancelled.
And maybe it's bot.
I don't know.
But I noticed this morning I was like, whoa!
Because I saw that I was at, like, 144.
And then now I'm at, like, 135.
So I was, like, crazy.
They discovered you smell...
No!
I have to think of something to do for 200k though.
I didn't think of anything for 100k.
So I have to think of something really good for 200k.
But I think I still have a little bit of time to think of
something.
So, I'll try.
Think of something.
Anyway, I'm gonna go to bed now.
Oh yeah, so I'm gonna go to bed now.
You ego-searching, huh?
Oh yeah, going to my own profile is totally ego-searching.
Yes, thank you.
Gosh.
Actually, you can't even ego-search my name.
Because you know what?
If you search Mint, all you get is a bunch of
cryptocurrency.
So I can't even ego-search me.
All you get is crypto.
It's impossible.
possible okay bye bye bye see you later see you tomorrow bye
bye bye bye bye bye